learning more about a bicyclist killed  in a reckless driving incident  michelle weisman was killed sunday  morning after she was  pushed by a passenger in a van driving  past her the passenger also  fell and died the driver was arrested  weisman was the hotel director of the  canary in north las vegas cannery excuse  me  boyd gaming released this statement on  her passing it reads  we are deeply saddened by the tragic and  senseless loss of our team member  shelly she was well known and well liked  by the entire  cannery team and we will miss her our  thoughts and prayers are with her family  and friends during this very difficult  time